please watch this entire video before
checking the blood flow in your leg
this video will teach you how to check
the blood flow in your leg good blood
flow is important for recovery after the
surgical procedure on your leg
step one look at your foot and toes on
the leg recovering from the surgical
procedure
compare your feet do you see any
differences
your foot and toes on the surgical side
should feel warm be normal in color and
have little to no swelling these signs
mean you have good blood flow in your
leg
if your foot looks red or blue feels
cool or has a lot of swelling your leg
may have poor blood flow
step two does your foot feel numb or
tingly a feeling of numbness and
tingling may also be a sign of poor
blood flow
or you may feel numbness from a type of
anesthesia called a nerve block until it
wears off
if you are not sure if you had a nerve
block ask your surgeon
step 3 wiggle your toes wiggling your
toes May improve blood flow to your foot
[Music]
repeat steps one through three every
four hours or as directed by your
surgeon
another way to check for good blood flow
is by doing a capillary refill test
capillaries are small blood vessels that
carry oxygen-rich blood to your toes the
capillary refill test allows you to see
how well blood is flowing through these
blood vessels to your toes on the
surgical side
step one
gently pinch the tip of your toe
directly over the toenail with your hand
step two squeeze until your toenail
turns white then let go
your toenail should turn pink again
within two to three seconds this sign
means that you have good blood flow in
your leg and foot
repeat steps one and two every four
hours or as directed by your surgeon
contact your surgeon if you notice your
foot looks red or blue
your foot looks very swollen
your foot feels cold numb or tingly
unless you had a nerve block during
surgery making your foot feel numb until
it wears off
or your toenail takes more than two to
three seconds to return to a pink color
when doing the capillary refill test
good